- I'm just gonna like throw out my phone,
I don't need you anymore.
Just kidding, I
desperately still need you.
(playful band music)
- This week, we are
trying to detach ourselves
from our phones using wearable technology.
- My personal struggle is just the anxiety
of constantly checking for messages
from certain individuals.
- I wanna try to curb the mindlessness
of just opening my phone
and swiping through.
- I'm on my phone before I
go to sleep, when I wake up,
at work, with my friends.
I'm just always on my phone.
- Didn't even think about it,
I just opened my phone
and went to my email.
- I sometimes see myself
missing parts of conversations.
- It is connecting me with
all these other people,
and not connecting me with the person
that's sitting right next to me.
- To track how much I use my phone,
we downloaded the Moment app.
- Yesterday, I used my phone
for five hours and 23 minutes.
- Five Hours.
- Three hours and 11 minutes.
That's really scary.
(upbeat rock music)
- Listen,
- It's very stylish.
- I'll set it for voice and texting.
- So, probably one for my mom, and my dad.
- Maybe my mother, if she calls.
Now that I'm saying that out loud,
I don't need to be checking
my phone all that often, huh.
- I'm hoping that this ring will serve as
when you tie something around
your finger to not forget.
- Three and a half hours of my
life, I want that time back.
I just set up my Ringly and
it's already annoying me
because it's just vibrating
while I'm just trying to get work done.
I don't need to know when my mom texts me
asking what Tanya from
High School is up to.
- It's been cool feeling
all the notifications,
but then I'll absolutely
check when they're happening.
- Moment app takes up
a lot of battery space,
so I'm actually using my phone less
because my phone's dying.
- I just got home from work,
and I've been on my phone for 45 minutes,
I didn't even realize it.
I'm a failure.
- My phone has made me aware of me
waking up and checking my email,
and text messages right away.
- So, I'm at the doctor's,
and I'm really bored,
but I brought a magazine with me today
because I figured I'm gonna be on my phone
so I brought something to
read and it's kind of helping.
- I've only been on for about two hours,
and it's now currently around
3 PM in the afternoon, so,
I think that's already a lot
less than what I've been using.
- The Ringly doesn't help me from
wanting to scroll through my
phone while I'm watching TV,
and it reminds me of the text
messages that I'm getting
while I'm watching TV, so it's
not super helpful with that.
Numbers from my phone have
only gone down like 30 minutes.
- I'm at a show right now, and
this friend is on her phone,
and this friend is on her phone.
Everyone's on their phone,
and I'm not allowed to be on my phone.
- The Ringly was awesome
in a meeting today,
because I have Google
Calendar alerts set up,
and it buzzed when it was 15 minutes
towards the end of the hour,
so I knew it was time to get
things going and finish up,
and it was a great moment
without having to look at my phone.
- So, I'm laying in bed
and all I want to do is check Instagram,
but I can't be on my phone right now,
so I'm gonna just try to go to sleep,
but I'm just constantly thinking about
what is happening on
Instagram Story right now.
- This feels like I'm being
nannied by an app on my phone.
So, it's Thursday, and I just woke up,
and I just looked at my phone to see
what my numbers were yesterday,
and I guess on Wednesday I went down
from three hours to two and half hours,
which isn't great, but
I'm making progress.
- So, I'm sitting outside,
and I haven't picked up my phone once.
- There's this guy, and
I'm trying not to text,
and I'm trying not to be
anxious, but, whatever.
And, it's a much better method
of not looking at your phone.
Like, this is the first
time I've looked at my phone
in maybe five hours all day.
- Just went to the market,
and it took me half the time,
'cause I wasn't checking
text messages the whole time.
- I sit outside, and not talk
to anyone for three hours,
which feels amazing.
- If you really want to
stop looking at your phone,
find yourself someone to crush on.
- So, the week's over, and I feel like,
now I have a much more
healthy relationship
with my phone than I did before.
- I went from being on
my phone for five hours
to being on my phone for
an hour and 50 minutes.
- Three hours and 40 minutes.
- One hour and 15 minutes a day.
- I've never stayed off
my phone for that long.
- It feels so light, and free.
- Instead of Snapchatting on my commute,
I was actually taking in the city
and talking with my friends more,
hanging out with my roommate more.
It gave me a whole new sense
of the life I was missing
outside of my phone.
- Probably just tied a
string around my finger
and called it a day.
- I would recommend just
actual, intentional motivation
to just curb your phone usage
rather than relying on
a piece of technology.
- What am I gonna do
with all that time now?
I don't know, maybe I'll take up knitting.